hey guys what's up so recently I decided
that I wanted to become a rock star but
there's a few problems number one I
can't sing and number two I can't play
guitar but I decided to learn I'm gonna
be using this game called rock Smith now
this is one of the first video games
that actually uses a real guitar and it
plugs directly into your guitar to your
xbox freakin amazing now not only am I
gonna learn to play this thing but I'm
also in a little competition with a few
other youtubers and I need your guys's
help to help me win this competition and
if I win I get to give away a Rocksmith
guitar package to you guys so all you
have to do is go to facebook.com slash
Rocksmith vote for me and when our team
wins I'm gonna give you guys a fantastic
Rocksmith package and a bunch of games
and then we're all gonna go on tour
maybe not the tour part definitely the
prizes part alright here's my Rocksmith
video diary
here we go along the guitar neck at the
correct fret position ready here it
comes
yes open string notes or horizontal
lines going across the entire note way
okay guys I've been practicing got my
guitar tuned and now I'm gonna I'm gonna
rock out
all right moving my high score this is
gonna be great
come on high score high score high score
yes oh well guys I don't think I'm gonna
be going on tour anytime too soon but
I'm gonna keep working on it and maybe
one day I will in the meantime check out
facebook.com slash Rocksmith and be sure
to vote for me has most improved because
when our team wins you guys win okay
whoever catches this pic type me in the
comments you get it get it okay bye